there's a lot of things that can go
wrong in launching something like this
you have half a million people so you
can look in a skyscraper look all the
way around Baltimore and be like more
than everyone I can see with my eyes has
registered for this event
I've been prepping for the presentation
for two weeks all day every day I will
not be the person who did not prepare
and I will do that work out of respect
for everyone else's attention offers was
a meta example meaning the book and the
course and everything it was was
purposely intended to be an offer so
good people would feel stupid saying no
the book itself was an example of the
concept of the book so 100 leads is
different in that I want the example for
the book not to be around the offer but
around how we promote the book about how
we got leads which is why this event was
so important to use all the different
advertising methods to promote the book
like I could have just made a post to my
audience about the book and sold plenty
of copies and not needed to do warm
Outreach or do Affiliates or do paid ads
what's the point of this meeting what
problem are we solving the most
expensive cost in almost all companies
is meetings that was supposed to be an
hour-long meeting and we got off in 28
minutes so what problem are we solving
the second is who's required to solve it
if we know what the decision is then
it's like I'm not needed so yeah it'll
be on Shopify reason we did on Shopify
was because um there's a bunch of issues
with Amazon done for launching but the
main one was that they wouldn't accept
the amount of books that we thought we
would sell Amazon limits any new book
usually to five thousand or ten thousand
heart backs and we had a pretty strong
suspicion that we were going to sell a
lot more than that so for that reason we
basically fronted all the money did all
the prints because we're self-published
so we're housing and we're shipping it
where we're housing it I don't like
anyone owning my stuff and so whenever
you publish a boat you actually sell the
rights to your content kind of like
musicians where they sell their music to
a label same concept for me to like give
you guys like a free chapter so the fact
that offers was 1.99 those are all
things that a normal publisher wouldn't
want me to do because that's where they
would make their money I want every
person there to watch this presentation
and be like I need to [__] work
harder like if that's like the deepest
takeaway from this whole thing then like
I can die pretty happy I mean most
people spend their entire lives not
being able to like influence 500 000
people and so like it's not lost on me
[Music]
my birthday [__] it yeah good morning
thank you appreciate it yes Trevor is
probably the closest thing to her
brother to me honestly we co-wrote the
books I I get a disproportionate amount
of credit but Trevor has definitely been
the one that has helped me beat up every
single idea he's been in a really
involved in my life for a long time now
and um I hope we can grow old and crotch
it together welcome everyone to my book
launch event I'm so pumped to have you
guys here I promise I have spent a very
long time time to compress days and
weeks and kind of like a stand-up
routine a standard routine that 60
Minutes has taken nine months to perfect
like each 30 second bit that strung
together created an hour and so it's
kind of the same way with this
presentation is that like it's zillions
of hours compressed into that and that's
why hopefully the value per second will
just be like incredibly High my first
presentations it was just like a few
words and then I would talk at the slide
over time and then I started adding more
like bullets and text to slide and then
I watched this presentation actually
changed my life it's a 15 minute Ted
Talk it was called like Death by
PowerPoint it actually like forever
changed how I made presentations which
is like one idea per slide but then I
got from the marketing and sales world
to pair the idea with a visual yeah I
just wanted to work that's all I want
for my birthday is that all the tech
works that's it I just want the links to
work I want the page to work I want the
processing to work
there's a huge amount of like Aussies
and new zealanders who are staying up as
like entrepreneur parties so cool yeah I
know so I've got a bunch of guys who
have like you know one thousand two
thousand person communities that are
helping each other up for the event
thank you
let's see what we got going on pre-set
up for tomorrow
check this out
this is the 360. wow when I dropped the
offer people will probably lose their
minds I have stacked it for like 17
minutes I just want to show the reaction
so the stack is a direct sales tactic
that has been proven so many times
across so many industries that it is
effective the goal for this presentation
was to be remembered and so if I wanted
someone to have an emotional experience
going through this then I have to
subvert the audience in a way I think
that the stack accomplished that
basically making a movie yeah basically
Zack Snyder
all right well okay rock and roll
please
what are the things that can go wrong
right now I really want me to go wrong
is what we can't control okay yeah just
like zoom in general
[Music]
it's the big day Yeah tomorrow's a big
day today is my birthday honestly I'm
just excited for you guys to tear into
it it's not even the event I'm excited
for the post that happened one day two
day three days four days later after
people have consumed you know read the
book cover to cover and read it a second
time and started going through the
course and listened to the audiobook
that's what I'm more excited about but
tomorrow is the first step to that and
uh I'll see you then
how many children we have we have over
100 000 in the check-in and currently on
the feed 66. cool I'm ready
damn right
Nigeria Bulgaria Philly Pakistan super
cool they're coming in international
baby yeah
around the world
just melts and melts it just puddles
so the nose trip said V1 of zero for the
last however many months our team has
used one-of-one content as kind of our
concept which is the only way we say
things that only you can say and show
things only you can show then as the
team started to find out all the things
that we're going to be releasing and
giving away and doing what no one else
would do the team said in the chat dude
this isn't even one of one this is one
of zero what are you doing that no one
will do and I think that raises the bar
a lot more I am scared by that bar but I
like that bar as an ideal to strive
towards
we're at 10 minutes
you ready gonna be a ride twists and
turns on this roller coaster
Layla's so worried she's like wait you
changed something it's like oh yeah
I'm excited to see the reactions because
there's gonna be 15 minutes of suspense
where they're like is he gonna sell
something right now what the good news
is I have done this before a lot of
times a lot of times I know how much
work I put into it when you're in front
of the crowd the only person's
confidence who matters is yours there
are men of talent and Men of preparation
I prefer to be the latter so little did
I know that as soon as I stepped on
stage uh like three massive Tech issues
uh break behind the scenes based on the
sheer volume of clicks that were going
at the same time to the same page
let's get some leads
is everything running smooth
I think a lot of people have any issues
with a low price
we had 562 000 link Clicks in a matter
of like 60 seconds whenever you have
something like that it's going to put
stress on systems that is very hard to
test for you can run simulators which we
had and we still had more people than
the infrastructure could handle I would
send them to YouTube so here's it so 140
000 people or so were not able to get in
the team pivoted on the Fly and provided
the YouTube link and we had another 40
or 50 000 people who made it over on
that side people can talk on their mice
in the zoom room yeah
the second thing was that there were
some Zoom rooms that the master Zoom
thing wasn't set up the right way so
that they they could like unmute
themselves rather than like webinar
presenter format now we ended up quickly
fixing that well expensively voting for
people now the YouTube live stream ended
up being three minutes delayed and those
were very three important minutes during
the uh the entire launch event and so we
were able to save 40 000-ish people on
YouTube but during that first five or so
minutes there was a lot of hustle and
bustle trying to figure out what we were
going to do to house literally a city of
people so you're gonna get lead magnet
Mastery you're gonna get the first five
client framework
Playbook you're gonna have the referral
Playbook and you're gonna get the
affiliate Playbook and the zero to 100
million dollar scaling roadmap from
someone who's actually been there total
value 1276. I could see the comments the
whole time and I say this with absolute
confidence I will bet that you cannot
see that I can see the comments in how I
was presenting how much is double your
lead flow worth an extra 10 000 a year
an extra 50 000
hundred thousand year
you knew that
everyone would turn on me for a brief
moment all I could think is like this is
going exactly how I want it I'm not
going to ask for 12 1076 even though
it'd be totally reasonable and a bargain
I'm not going to ask for four thousand
nine hundred ninety seven dollars I'm
not even asked for two thousand nine
hundred ninety seven dollars I'm gonna
give you access to everything we talked
about today
for a single payment of
[Music]
taking the extra four seconds five
seconds when the world is watching I
wanted to sit in it and just hold and
just like kind of enjoy the moment a
single payment of
I know what they don't know and I
believe that that's how some of the best
sales presentations are supposed to be I
went from villain to hero in 10 seconds
it's free
we're already almost halfway on Adam
looking good oh thank you thanks sweetie
um
I appreciate it
there were some dark days in the middle
of the stack there you gotta touch the
bottom of the pool that's what makes it
memorable despite all the hate that I
was getting I knew the rubber band was
going to snap back the moment they saw
the truth they just had to wait roller
coaster ride
[Music]
you have no idea like I was so nauseous
I think I am gonna throw off
I think that more people trust us now to
continue to keep our promises in a world
that breaks them and more people believe
us when we say we are a long-term
focused because we didn't take the 50
million dollar payday right there was
one comment was actually my favorite
comment on all the ones that I that I
saw you could have made bank but you
chose to make history and I thought that
was like that was the [__] point like
in a statement that was the point
good job that was just only two years of
Our Lives just about a hundred thousand
books sold the first day so offers just
sold just under 500 000 copies over two
years to sell a hundred thousand in a
day was pretty cool to sell 20 of offers
of sold big shoes to fill but I actually
think that lease with some more copies
that offers us and I think that's
because more people perceive they have
the problem of not having leads than not
having an offer the aftermath we're not
even done the first week because I'm
recording this but my name was trending
on all of Twitter the leads audiobook is
seven on all of Amazon we went from 50
to 26 on all podcasts we're number one
in entrepreneurship we're number two in
business like I'm actually like
emotional about it something that has
never been done before I actually truly
believe that what he just did with this
launch is going to just have shock waves
do you agree with people that are saying
that you changed the industry
if we're defining change the industry as
many people will act differently in
terms of how they do business afterwards
then I would say yes not everyone but
certainly some people will the people
who have longer time Horizons who want
to build bigger more lasting businesses
for sure a brand is based on the
associations that people make I knew
that having a massive historic event and
having the thing still be more valuable
than everyone else's and free was
something that I wanted to associate
myself with but if you measure on a
one-year time Horizon
then it will never make sense
it's cool this is very cool
I just want to say thank you guys so
much for coming out it means the world
to me it's one of those like very small
things that Trevor and I spent two years
writing this book I just want to say
thank you it means a lot to us
at the end of the day I will die and on
a longer time Horizon I will be
forgotten and the only thing that I can
say that helped that might be Eternal is
skills and education that I can pass on
to other people Trevor used to tell me
when I was going through kind of like
harder times with the edits because it
was very tough to edit this book and
write this book he said there's a 17
year old who's going to sleep with this
book under his pillow to get out of this
situation you owe it to him and that's
what was kind of like the continuously
reinforcing mental frame that I had to
that would pull me through it